-Andrea,
welcome to the show.
-Thanks for having me.
-Congrats.
"Con Pollo" is officially out.
It's out this week.
It's officially in bookstores.
It's out.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Have you been
to bookstores yet to see it?
-I have, but I think the most
surreal thing I've seen, so far,
is that I was walking
down Midtown -- or in Midtown
-Yeah.
-and I see a giant billboard
with Pollo on it.
And I had never
in my life imagined
I would see a 30-foot Pollo
on the side of a building...
-Yeah, that you --
-...but I did.
-That you drew.
-Yeah, that, too, that I drew.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah. You're
amazingly talented.
I want to talk about your
background a little bit
because, a few years ago,
you were doing
something very different.
-Yeah, so, back in 2020,
I was in a marketing job,
really questioning
what was next,
what I should really be doing,
and, at that point,
I decided that I knew I wanted
to be doing
something more creative
and had my heart set on being
a full-time photographer.
So, I mustered up the courage
to quit my job
and leave that stability behind
and decided to go freelance
in January 2020,
not knowing that March 2020
-Wow.
-was coming
and, effectively,
because of that,
I became unemployed overnight,
was really like stressed
and overwhelmed.
And I think we all kind of coped
in different ways
-Yeah.
-in those early pandemic days.
I just drew.
I drew and I drew and I drew.
It brought me so much peace
and comfort.
It was like this little safe
space I created for myself.
And, somewhere along the line,
I was like,
"You know what I miss?
I miss talking to people.
You know, I miss interacting
with people.
-Yeah.
So, I'm going
to share these online
and just like have fun with it."
And, before I knew it,
I had built
a little bit
of an online community
that was really supportive
of me and my artwork
and started me
down this brand-new path.
-What is your name, again,
on Instagram?
It's @...?
-It's @dreasdoodles.
-@dreasdoodles.
-Yeah.
-And you posted one
that got a lot of attention.
It was a drawing you did
of Martin Luther King Jr.
-I did.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-And...
[ Whistling ]
...it got a lot of attention,
being liked
by very famous people,
including our very own Questlove
liked this drawing as well.
-Yeah, he shared it.
Thank you.
That was surreal
because this was something
that really came from the heart,
where I felt like it was
an important message to share,
so, seeing folks like Questlove
share it,
Wanda Sykes, Octavia Spencer,
I was like, "Okay,
maybe there's something here.
Maybe I should, you know,
pursue this drawing thing
professionally.
Maybe I can really use
my artistic skills
to tackle different topics
and subjects.
-Yeah.
And then
when did you find out
that we were working together?
-Actually, at a really
interesting point
in my art journey.
I had been pitching myself
for months and months
to different art directors
and editors
and getting absolutely
zero responses,
so, I was feeling
like really defeated.
Like, "Okay, maybe I was wrong.
Maybe I should go back
to the marketing job."
And that's when I got an email
from Macmillan Publishing
and I was like, "Wait. What?"
Again, in my pity party state,
like,
"This publishing house
is asking me
to illustrate a picture book?
This can't be real.
I need to google them.
This is probably a scam."
Like I don't know
what's going on.
I google them.
They're a very real company.
-[ Scoffs ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And a very big deal.
So, I'm like, "Oh, okay,
let me respond
and kind of just see
what they say."
So, I tell them, "I'm absolutely
interested in learning more
about this picture book.
Tell me more."
And that's when
they very calmly are like,
"Great. This picture book
is about a bilingual pollo."
I'm like,
"Oh, that sounds really cool."
"Oh, by the way,
the book is written
by Jimmy Fallon
and Jennifer Lopez."
[ Laughter ]
¿Qué?
I'm sitting in like
my little pity party,
gray on gray outfit in the rain,
just like --
[ Laughter ]
-Gray on gray.
-Yeah, it's my outfit.
Just like so sad,
looking at this email
and there's like a bunch
of different scenarios playing
in my brain.
I'm like, "Okay, well,
how is this all going
to play out?"
And I can tell you,
wholeheartedly,
none of that included this,
[ Laughter ]
like this, at all.
-Right.
-Or a 30-foot Pollo.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-This is it.
-I mean, right?
-[ Laughs ]
-So, once --
-I'm so happy.
-Yeah, once I kind of processed
that, I'm like,
"Well, I'm obviously going
to say say yes."
And then I make a promise
to myself.
I'm like, "Okay,
you're not going to be able
to control the outcome of this,
but what you can control is
designing the cutest,
baddest chicken
the world has ever seen
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
-"and hope
that everyone loves it."
-And I wanted to show you this.
We actually --
We made it into a plushie.
[ Awws and applause ]
This is Pollo.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-He's so cute!
-This is you!
You drew this!
-I know.
-You made this!
-That's yours!
She's so cute, right?
-So cute!
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheering and applause
continue ]
-I'm so thankful.
You're so talented.
This is just the beginning
of many, many things.
And thank you so much
for everything
and coming on the show, Andrea.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Andrea Campos, everybody.
"Con Pollo" is out now!